je suis à poil dehors la nuit avec elle
claire de lune on a poil qu'est-ce que
je fous là quoi c'est un moment où moi
j'étais encore la maternelle comment
j'ai pu atterrir là c'est un truc de ouf
à côté de toi je sais qu'on est pas seul
je sais qu'il y en a d'autres et il me
touche je sais pas quel âge il avait
mais c'est un mec formé quoi il était
c'était un adulte enfin il y avait un
corps d'adulte en tout cas et j'ai cette
sensation d'interdit de faut pas faire
de bruit ça je me souviens très bien
faut pas réveiller
les gens qui dorment dans la dans la
baraque il y a un sentiment de dégoût
aussi de Fort dégoût ce qu'on a vécu ça
va être violent écouter mais la moindre
des choses c'est de l'écouter
je t'ai confiné ici et puis comme tout
le monde au bout d'un moment tu te dis
quelque chose je suis allé à la cave je
suis allé partout ranger les pas plats
les machins les patins les couffins et
puis je suis tombé sur un très très
vieille photo c'est une photo noir et
blanc qui avait été prise quand j'étais
petite à la mer où je suis avec des des
cousins des cousines des frangins des
frangines et où il y a donc un de mes
agresseurs enfin en tout cas celui le
familial on va l'appeler comme ça qui me
tient comme ça et là j'ai ressenti un
truc vraiment nauséeux un gros malaise
et là ça a été c'est revenu et j'ai eu
des flashs
[Musique]
cette sensation je me souvenais où il me
tenait et il me frottait
pas forcément comme j'étais sur lui
comme ça il y avait mon public qui était
contre lui et je me rappelle qui j'ai
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fout il frottait ça
sur son dos quoi et puis avec lui un
mouvement de bassin etc parce que
malheureusement
c'est ça qui est vraiment dingue c'est
qui on se dit souvent mais comment
comment les autres n'ont pas vu quoi
[Musique]
dans ma famille c'était fais gaffe quand
tu vas à l'école tu arrêtes quand
quelqu'un s'arrête tu montes pendant la
bagnole tu réponds pas
l'extérieur il peut y avoir un danger
pour toi en tant que petite fille
des agressions sexuelles c'est à
l'intérieur des familles c'est ça qui
est difficile qui amène aussi ce truc
parce qu'on se dit mais en fait je suis
une je suis même pas une merde je suis
un objet une merde encore c'est
organique c'est vivant là c'est un objet
dont on te prend comme on veut on te
fait faire ce qu'on veut et si au bout
d'un moment tu finis par le croire
pourquoi je me suis je me suis retrouvé
dans des situations où j'étais la proie
d'autres gens pourquoi je me suis
retrouvé
à me prostituée la prostitution c'est
c'est partout c'est dans le métro c'est
c'est dans une soirée c'est dans une
discothèque c'est c'est pas forcément en
échange de d'un bifton c'est en échange
de d'aller dormir chez quelqu'un parce
que tu as la rue c'est en échange de
d'une bouffe c'est inscrit dans ton âme
dans ta chair et dans ton cerveau que tu
ne sers qu'au bon vouloir de certains et
tu demandes pourquoi donc tu dis ben je
suis folle en fait je suis folle je suis
une mauvaise personne culpabilité honte
culpabilité honte
c'est violent quand on se rappelle c'est
violent parce que c'est ça remue plein
de choses et puis surtout on sait pas où
on est des seuls le coup c'est comme si
on s'en fout un gros projet dans la
gueule qui éclaire comme ça des morceaux
de mémoire des morceaux de souvenirs
donc c'est très violent mais
mais le pire est derrière je sais pas
comment l'expliquer mais il y a un truc
qui fait que
je sais c'est qu'il faut jamais forcer
quelqu'un à parler ça ça c'est la règle
numéro 1 parce que c'est une deuxième
agression la victime elle fait comme
elle peut on subit toute et tous
se voile cette chape de plomb parce que
des moments c'est tellement c'est
tellement horrible ce qu'on ressent ça
débouche sur des
sur Bluetooth destruction sur des
suicides sur la toxicomanie
tentative de suicide et tout ça en plus
tout ça c'est des chiffres déclarés ce
qui veut dire que avec l'omerta et tout
le bordel c'est beaucoup plus c'est
beaucoup plus
on gré d'un mot d'une photo d'un film
d'un documentaire comme celui que vous
allez voir d'Andrea ou d'une discussion
il y a un truc qui apparaît et le voile
il commence à craquer
pour soulever ce voile et pouvoir en
parler il y a que la personne victime
qui qui sait qui sent comment il faut
faire comment il faut en parler je
reçois plein de messages de gens que je
connais pas sur les réseaux sociaux qui
disent merci de mettre des mots sur mes
mots ouvrez votre gueule vous n'êtes pas
tout seul moi je suis là on est des
milliers des millions dans ce cas là et
ça c'est une force aussi notre force à
nous les victimes c'est d'être
nombreuses et nombreux et avec ça on
peut faire bouger les choses mais force
enfants des ados qui t'écoutent en ce
moment et qui sont victimes de ça tu
leur dirais quoi surtout s'ils sont pas
encore en mesure de parler vous emballez
pas je suis allé ce que vous pouvez
hurler ce que vous pouvez
évidemment que le but c'est d'ouvrir sa
gueule et c'est très dur ne culpabiliser
pas surtout c'est pas à vous de
culpabiliser c'est pas vous la honte
elle est pas sur vous la honte elle est
sur celui qui vous agressé moi je te
crois moi je te crois moi ancienne
victime je te crois tout le monde là on
te croit donc prends cette force là avec
toi et va vers un mieux demande de
l'aide par le sang je parle aussi aux
gamins et aux gamines qui entendent un
copain une copine dire un truc ou qui
voit un comportement bizarre il vaut
mieux alerter et qui ne se soit rien
passé ça c'est pas grave mais je t'en
supplie fais pas ça quoi fais pas ça ça
c'est ça qui tue les victimes c'est ça
et c'est ça alors ouvre ta gueule ouf ta
gueule